foreign
Joe is up in Oklahoma City Oklahoma Joe
how can we help
hey there guys my Dad recently offered
to buy me my wife a new car but he would
be leasing it
um I'm just really calling him to see
should we accept it and if we did how do
we go about that
I don't like almost anything about the
situation that's a weird form of
generosity because you're putting him
into debt is it in his name and you're
just driving it the title in your name
and the loans in his
so the title would be in his name
um no he would just be giving it to us
and we wouldn't have to make any
payments no no this is just no Haywire
man I would not accept this I'd say hey
I appreciate the generosity uh it's very
kind of you but this is going to put you
in a precarious situation and we want to
own whatever we are driving and we want
it to be in our name and I appreciate
that if you want to gift us if you want
to write a check to help us purchase a
new car in cash or to use car in cash we
would love that but we don't want you
going into debt and robbing your future
for this gift
that's how I would put it as nicely as
possible
yeah okay what would he say to that
well
I told him that and he he he just
replied back
um to accept it and to uh uh yeah just
to accept it so me and my wife have just
been talking about it there's nothing
real it's more of just in the talks but
knowing my dad uh it's very possible it
could happen and so
um how's he doing financially is he like
in an amazing spot would you say uh he
he is um I think he's in a good spot but
now managing his finances is another
thing so I think that's why it makes me
worried yeah listen listen how old are
you
I'm 22. dude you're a grown man
yeah like that whole no one my dad is
gonna happen and you're just resigning
yourself to it and I if you called us
for permission we're not going to give
you the permission if you called us for
verification that what you were feeling
is correct that he shouldn't do this you
don't want to do this then you are in
fact right and you it's time for you to
man up and say pop I don't want it I'm
not going to take it and here's the
reason why thank you I'm very grateful
this is not a good Financial move for
you and I don't want to be a part of it
I don't need it
yeah do you have a car right now
yeah me and my wife both have two cars
paid off and they're fine yeah are you
needing to upgrade one
uh no I would love a truck but we don't
we don't need one so now let me say this
Joe there's no you can't stop your dad I
mean if he goes out and puts a lease in
his name but but you don't have to drive
you can say hey I told you not to do
this I'm begging you not to do it I'm
not going to drive and then tell them
you're gonna have to pay the stupid tax
because you're gonna lose money on this
deal after you have to get out of the
lease right and I don't want that for
you what do you think is motivating this
Joe
I think
um a little bit of it is that whenever I
was growing up he him and my family
weren't at the place that they're at now
financially and so I think now one of
the things that plays into it is he
wants to
um you know kind of I guess
give me something we didn't have growing
up yeah um even though I wouldn't have
had a truck growing up I thought of this
but yeah I would acknowledge that when
you tell them say hey I appreciate what
you're doing and this it's awesome and
I'm but it it I don't regret anything I
don't resent you you know like I I would
add some of that to this conversation
you know and if he wants to do something
smaller for you say hey there's other
ways that you could bless us that that I
think are you know much more financially
responsible maybe uh Jello of the month
club you know I don't know is that a
real thing the gift that keeps on giving
isn't that funny like Christmas Vacation
nobody wants that gift no nobody does
it's my point like you don't need to
bless us dad like you don't have to give
us something do you know you raised me
to be independent and I'm a grown man
now and I want to do this on my own and
own it and really feel the ownership and
I feel like if you gifted to us we're
not going to be able to do that yeah and
so if you want to write us a check later
on in life that can help go towards that
truck I'd love that but no pressure yeah
just take the the like you don't have to
do this dad you know yeah and yeah and
that I think hopefully comes from a
spirit of gratitude and humility and
hopefully that'll work so tough stuff
though yeah appreciate the call yeah
thank you that's uh a dad who means well
and but creates a really awkward
situation and then obviously a bad
financial situation for himself how many
calls do we get where the kids are going
hey my parents didn't take care of
themselves financially and now we have
to right and that's what I see in the
next 20 years for this guy absolutely